my faith is a faithfulness to a process
of self-correction not to any one
faculty as the voice of the Divine I
think the capacity for um the self
correction to take on a life of its own
and a life on its own that plugs into uh
transpersonal and transc of aspects of
my being for me that is a better I'm
very impressed that you managed to bring
all of that back to the point where it
started by the
[Music]
way
hello everybody I have the pleasure
today of talking with my colleague at
the University of Toronto Dr John Veri
we've
discussed much many times on my podcast
and in public and so it's a continuation
of a conversation that's been going on
for a very long time we concluded today
with the proposition that we're both
working on the edge of what you might
describe as the counter Enlightenment
which I suppose is the Endeavor to
place what would you
say cognitive processes that have gone
to astray into the abstract and
representational back on their feet to
ReDiscover the sacred to ReDiscover
what's deep and meaningful to rectify
the meaning crisis as a consequence of
that rediscovery and new discovery and
we delve farther into that today so
welcome aboard hopefully it's useful
practically and
metaphysically I've got a idea about the
sacred I want to run by you sure
technically
well imagine that you have a hierarchy
of thinkers such that this
would exist over time okay such that
some
thinkers have more thinkers dependent on
them than other thinkers right so
they're more seminal right you'd get a
rough approximation of that with
citation counts in the scientific
Endeavor and citation counts are a
pretty good index of quality as well as
quantity at least compared to every
other index that we have so you can
imagine a dependency structure among
thinkers So that obviously a thinker
like Milton would be of primary depth
and Shakespeare the people who are part
of the Canon and so rather than
conceptualizing the Canon as a
consequence of the arbitrary decisions
of Arbiters of taste let's say you could
say that the Canon is the consequence of
the cumulative impact of a thinkers
thoughts moving forward and some
thinkers are more key than others um
my sense for example and there's
historical reasons for this obviously
that the biblical Corpus stands at the
bottom of the western Cannon and then
there are thinkers who are who have
their foot feet placed firmly in that
tradition Dante Milton Shakespeare Etc
and then a a branching structure above
all that okay so it's a matter of
dependency and
so how
fundamental a given thought is is
dependent on how many other thoughts are
dependent on it for its validity okay
now this works out neuropsychologically
too so imagine that you have a janof
Balman who talked about trauma has a
theory that's analogous to this and I
think it fits in well with the entropy
control theories of friston so then
imagine that your perceptions and
therefore your emotional regulation are
dependent upon a nested sequence of
assumptions the the and a given
phenomenon can violate an assumption and
the degree of entropy that's produced by
the Assumption violation is
proportionate to the depth of the
Assumption right right so yanov bolman
talks about for example her model of
trauma is shattered assumption the
deeper the Assumption so for example one
way you can be traumatized in a marital
relationship is through the discovery of
infidelity yeah yeah right your your
hyper priers get destroyed yeah so what
do you call them hyper priors in the
basian brain framework in friston's
framework the the sort of priors that
you use to run any of the basian
approximation I actually don't like
using the basian math because you don't
actually run the math you run uh a
dynamical system approximation but
that's how they talk about it in the
literature these are these are sort of
your most Prof these are the things that
are uh applied in your predictive
modeling in the most context invariant
manner so they apply right context
invariant right right well that's
another way of thinking about it too is
that
something more fundamental applies
across more situations and time spans
right okay okay so here's a secondary
consequence of that I think so then
imagine that the degree to which you can
handle
entropy emerging as a consequence of the
violation of your assumptions is
proportionate to your social status okay
and the reason for that is
that the the better your reputation and
therefore the better your situation in
the social environment it happens to be
the more resources you can bring to bear
on a problem if one emerges okay now
imagine your serotonin system index is
that because we know serotonin is one of
the systems that's implicated in the
relationship between social status and
emotional regulation sure so now the
serotonin system has inputs into the
memory systems that are that have this
hyper dependency structure and they're a
tuner and so that for you imagine
disruption would be characterized in
terms of its estimated magnitude by the
depth of the presumption that was being
violated and then there's a control
mechanism off to the side of that such
that the more tenuous your grip on the
social environment is the higher the
level of negative emotion that's
produced in relationship to the
violation of a given level of of
assumption sure right okay okay so that
makes that makes sense to you that seems
to be reasonable very clar yeah okay
okay okay okay good okay well so then
I've been working well I'm writing as I
mentioned a book on on uh on explication
of biblical narrative it's called we who
wrestle with God and I've been working
oh nice pun on Israel yes yes right
exactly exactly and I discovered that
relationship when I did the lectures
lectures on Genesis in in
so I've been kind trying to come up with
a technic technical definition of the
Sacred right and and this is relevant to
research on awe too so the deeper you go
the closer you get to the sacred and and
I'm I'm speaking as a matter of
definition here so as you move down your
assumption hierarchy and you get to
these you call them hyper priors yeah
the closer you get to the ultimate hyper
prior the the the the the the more
you're walking on sacred ground and
that's a technical definition now if you
encounter something that shifts you in a
hyper prior and that's a positive
encounter that's going to produce a
corresponding sensation of awe right and
that I would say that's probably a
dopaminergically mediated revelation of
possibility it's okay so let me run
something else by you and tell me what
you think about this okay okay so I've
been
conceptualizing the sacred as a process
too so there's a spirit in the Old
Testament that's characterized as yahwa
and the theory in the Corpus is that
whatever this Central spirit is makes
itself manifest in a number of different
guises so for Noah for examp example God
is the spirit that calls the wise to
prepare when the flood is coming and for
Abraham God is the call of the spirit of
Adventure and so you see these
juxtapositions of narratives that shed a
different light on this Central spirit
with each story United by the claim that
regardless of the surface differences of
the manifestation of this spirit it's
reflecting an underlying Unity that's
the monotheistic hypothesis one God
underneath all the gods so a dependency
structure that has a fundamental base or
a pinnacle depending on which set of
metaphors that you use so when I wrote
maps of meaning I had started to
conceptualize the call of the sacred as
something like spontaneous interest
right is that well so things will grip
your attention and compel you in a
certain direction I realized later after
I wrote that book many years later that
that was equivalent to the more
traditional notion of call fall in and
so and then I think I missed something
in maps of meaning that's half of the
Divine because I I really concentrated
on interest and that was sort of under
the influence of humanistic
psychologists who were oriented towards
say
self-actualization but there's a
corresponding element of conscience and
so the there are
conceptualizations by Cardinal Newman
for example of God as the internalized
voice of conscience right like the
source of the super ego that's not
that's another way of thinking about it
but then you could think of yahwa as
sort of the dynamic relationship between
calling and conscience and to me that
Maps nicely onto positive and negative
emotion because a calling is going to
entice you forward with dopaminergically
mediated what would you what would you
say indications of treasure to come and
conscience is going to say you've
deviated off the Golden path into the
domain of danger and there's something
you should sort out and then
well you see and you see quite clearly
in the Old Testament Corpus and it also
emerges in the New Testament that
there's a dynamic relationship between
conscience and calling and that looks to
me like what's conceptualized as the
holy spirit that Dynamic
relationship so wow that's a lot well
it's I've been working on this for
months you know so yeah so so
interesting because I've been working on
this sacred a lot
too starting a business can be tough
especially knowing how to run your
online store front thanks to Shopify
it's easier than ever Shopify is the
global Commerce platform that helps you
sell at every stage of your business
from the launch your online shop stage
all the way to the did we just hit a
million orders stage Shopify is there to
help you grow our marketing team uses
Shopify every day to sell our
merchandise and we love how easy it is
to add more items ship products and
track conversions Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms no matter how big you
want to grow Shopify gives you
everything you need to take control and
take your business to the next level
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're at that's shopify.com
jvp let me share my thoughts and I'll
share where I think they intersect with
yours but maybe they differ but I think
in a fruitful way um first of all I um
there's sort
of um in in the literature I've been
reading there's sort of three dimensions
that are usually talked about with
respect to the sacred um one is ultimacy
which I think you
articulating um and this and the move
you made and this is a compliment to you
by the way is is the classic move of
neoplatonism which is called asymmetric
dependence so what is everything
asymmetrically dependent on that's how
you get your ultimate what is that in
terms of which everything else is
explained or understood right that's
ultimacy um and then two other
dimensions of the sac which I think
you're alluding to um one is axiological
that you love this ultimate it isn't
just an intellectual grasp for you so
that's the directionality yes and and
there's there's there's a valuing
there's a loving but it's the reason why
I want to say love rather than just
value is love love doesn't carry with it
necessarily the egocentrism of of value
which can be very egocentrically
oriented so love is so so would that be
maybe that would be expressed in the Old
Testament Corpus as part of the
covenantal relationship because it's a
personal relationship rather than a than
a what would you say instrumental
relationship yeah EST like me argues
that in her covenantal epistemology and
loving to know and how there's this deep
B bond between uh knowing god and loving
God that you can't separate them right
and so that's so that's conceptualized
metaphorically in the guise of a
relationship rather than as having
something oh yes it's very much about
being in relationship and that's why I
want to use the word love you can have
preferences or even values but you have
to be in love it's a commitment of the
whole self right and so and the thing
about love is is it gets you on Plato's
pivot point it involves the whole of the
self without being self- involved which
seems to be another dimension of this
calling the sacred doesn't just call
your aesthetic interest or your ethical
interest or your intellectual calls you
as a complete person this is one of the
things that till emphasized speaks to
the image of God within yes and you know
the Trad the Christian tradition of the
transmutation of the image into the
likeness um and so I think it's that's
the axiological dimension and then
there's the serological dimension that
this loving relationship to what is
Ultimate um is transformative it's
healing it's Redemptive it's liberating
uh and so the reason why this is
important is of course is this allows
the sacred to be found in things that
are in non-theistic Traditions like
Buddhism the da right things like that
so I the first part of what you were
talking about like I said um and again I
think this this speaks well of it is in
lines with the classic neoplatonic
proposal of um that what we're trying to
get in touch with what is most real we
have to get to the ground of
intelligibility through at asymmetric
dependence this is the notion of the
ultimate the one asymmetrical dependence
is that the terminology that's used yeah
Kevin Corgan uses that when he tries to
talk about how platinus U makes his
argument for the one the Ultimate
Reality within the neoplatonic system
which gets taken up um well one of the
ways of sorting through that as far as
I'm concerned is to note that there's
either a Unity or there's a plurality
and then to note what the consequences
of those are if there's a plurality
there's in built contradictions in the
structure of being and becoming itself
and there's divisiveness that can't be
overcome if there's an ultimate unity it
might be mysterious and ineffable but it
does indicate that all things can be
brought together in some sort of
harmonious relationship and that's
relevant to human motivation because if
there's a plurality there's going to be
confusion and anxiety because confusion
and anxiety Mark a plurality so well
yeah this is Kirk guard's purity of
heart is to will one thing um so right
right and so but this again is a
neoplatonic argument the idea is
whenever we're understanding something
what we're doing is taking two things
and finding a unifying principle and
then if you were to pursue understanding
to its depths you'd get something that
technically speaking can't be understood
because it is the principle by which all
understand everything is understood
right right right right so what what
you'll get is you so it grounds out
ineff ineffability it grounds out
ineffability and and if you look at like
Nicholas of kuza where it grounds out is
it grounds out in sort of of the
paradoxical realization that what we
consider ultimates ultimate polarities
are actually somehow stereoscopically
transcended so for example the even
though the term is the one right it is
understood as being Beyond Singularity
and plural plurality it is neither
singular nor plural because it is the
basis for that particular kind of
intelligibility it is trans Centric God
is an intelligible sphere whose Center
is everywhere and whose circumference is
nowhere is that Nicholas of C uh well it
was taken up by uh Nicholas and others
but it was actually um that's a great
that's a great line yeah and well
Nicholas has one that goes with it that
God is within everything but not
enclosed and Beyond everything but not
excluded oh yeah yeah yeah right right
and so that that's ultimacy and then the
idea is um and this comes from yaden's
work and some of my own work when people
come into relationship to that which
they consider more real the really real
they take on this loving relationship
ship in that they seek to transform
their identities and their lives you
suppose that's a marker for the validity
of the encounter like if you if you
stumble across something that entices
you into a relationship of Love Is that
actually a reliable ontological marker
let's say well I think it I think if two
things line up yes I think the answer is
yes I think that's an excellent question
I think if you get the reciprocal
opening that's found in love uh for
example uh you know I have a wonderful
partner uh and I come to understand that
there's something about her that will
always be beyond my grasp and I open up
to that and she opens up to that in me
and we reciprocally open and Aaron
that's that's how you fall in love with
so I think and from the first person
perspective it's yes but I I think yayen
and other people have done work that
when people have this sense of being
called and they have this noetic
experience of the really real they do
make their lives better by meaning
objective measures their relationships
get better well you mentioned healing so
I've been wrestling about that
physiologically well partly because I've
been writing about the gospels and about
a quarter to a third of the Gospel
account is miracles of healing right
which is a difficult that's difficult
ground to tread on if
you're an empirical materialist let's
say if you're a naturalist exactly
exactly but there's a another frame of
interpretation which doesn't necessarily
exclude the miraculous but at least
sidesteps it for the moment possibly or
brings them together to suggest that
well if the pattern of being that Christ
represents is a Divine ideal there's
every reason to assume that it would be
allied with the kind of healing that you
were describing which so imagine that
you could embody a spirit a set of
practices a set of perceptions and
emotions that would optimize your
function in relationship to the
Transcendent there's every reason to
assume that that that what would
accompany that would be an optimization
of psychop physiological IAL function me
that's that's no different than claiming
that you're going to have a much higher
risk for mortality if you're depressed
which is well known right so there there
there are certainly there are links
between attitude and underlying thriving
that are well established and it it's
not unreasonable to point out that like
the archetypal ideal would that
manifestation of the archetypal ideal or
even contact with the archetypal ideal
would be something that would tap you
hard in a healing Direction
I think so and I mean
um so I I one of the arguments I've been
working on is well you know I mean you
know this better than I do I mean one of
P's great insights the thing that made
him a brilliant scientist right is he
was looking for systematicity in the
error being produced in the psychometric
measures of intelligence just just that
move alone is brilliant everybody else
treats the errors as noise he says well
what if there's patterns in the error
and if the patterns if there's
systematicity that points to intrinsic
constraints and developmental Arc and
all that and and and that alone is
brilliant and then I've sort of been
reflecting on that and connecting with
some of the literature and insight which
is to think well if there's
systematicity of error there's also the
possibility of systematicity of insight
which is not an insight into this
particular problem but an insight into a
family or network of problems such that
right it would be lead to a systematic
transformation of one's orientation and
grip on the world and would also be
systemic it would tend to percolate
through the entire psyche that's what a
baptism is well I mean it can be I mean
um well well right right that's the
transformation that a baptism is
designed to bring about if it's possible
yeah and I I mean I think the shamanic
death and rebirth Abol I think the great
doubt in zazen is doing it um um and you
know well that's what happened to dayart
too how so how do you think well he
decided that he was going to doubt
everything right and to take it to take
a journey down to what to what would you
say the land of the fundamental
presumption something like that and my
sense with dayart I mean it's his
realization is often translated as I
think therefore I am but I don't really
think that that's how he would have
conceptualized it had he been alive now
I would I think it's something more like
I'm conscious therefore I am or I can't
doubt the the fundamental reality of my
own well I'll I'll put it back to you in
way way I it and let's say we're so
before the Scientific Revolution in
decart we have a contact epistemology we
have the epistemology that when you and
I when you know something the form of
that not the shape the form of it the
the the principle of intelligibility in
it is identical in your mind and the
thing they conform together so this is a
contact epistemology it's a mutual
participation and then of course when we
get the because of cernus and Kepler we
get this separation and the divorce I
talk about this a lot in Awakening from
the meaning crisis and what dayart does
is he tries to find where there's still
that contact and where he finds it
remaining is in
self-consciousness the mind's contact
with itself is where that knowing by
being is still to be found and he
withdraws the problem we have faced
since that is you can't get contact with
the world from that contact of the mind
with itself um and so this is what a lot
of the work I'm engaged in is about
trying trying to overcome what's
interesting is that dayart on on notes
to a lot of people of course Dart puts a
lot of emphasis on logic uh but deard
also puts quite a bit of emphasis on
Insight that moment of insight when you
where you get the Flash and so the all
of the premises of the argument hang
together that's
crucial do you well okay I want to go a
couple of directions from from all
that I've been thinking about thought
itself as a form of secularized Prayer
okay so so let me okay so let me lay out
lay out what I've been thinking and tell
me tell me what you've been thinking and
and what you think about this so the
first the first issue is this is
that we say we think things up but we
have no idea what that means because the
phenomenology this is something by the
way that Yung Carl Yung caught in me on
to to some degree he said that we come
across our own thoughts like we come
across the furniture in a room it's like
they're laid out before us and so and
that always struck me
because being struck by a thought or
having a thought appear in your internal
landscape
is well I think it's a revelation I
don't think it's any different than a
revelation and
so here's the steps as far as I can tell
of thought the first step is something
like a confession and the confession is
whatever I think about this is
insufficient which is equivalent in part
to thinking I'm insufficient right so
it's a humble step I have to not know
something and that not knowing has to be
of motivational significance and then
that has to be allied with wanting to
know okay and that has to be allied with
faith that knowing would be better than
ignorance and that's a presumption man
especially because lots of times when
you get a revelatory thought you're
going to pay a price for your knowledge
which might be the catastrophic
dissolution of some of your previous
assumptions right so you have to have
this
axiomatic presumption that more
knowledge is good in the ways that would
be desirable to you and even more
generally and I think that's something
like faith in the essential goodness of
being and its intelligibility itself and
I think that's partly why the scientific
Endeavor is embedded in that Assumption
of the goodness of being and the
goodness of knowledge anyways no I agree
with that okay okay okay so with regards
to I want to talk to you about that at
some point I call Extended okay we'll go
we'll get back to that so with regard to
re so the first is admission of
insufficiency yes and then there's the
positing of a question and that seems to
me to be alied with this gospel
insistence that if you knock the door
will open and if you ask you'll receive
and if you seek you'll find all that all
depends on actually asking actually
wanting to know actually seeking it it
can't be a game you got to want to know
you know one of the things I've noticed
in my own life is for example if I'm
having a problem communicating with my
wife or I'm having a scrap with a member
and there's a certain amount of pain in
it that if I sit down and I say probably
I'm contributing to some something to
this I'd like to know what it is which
is not a fun thing to do no no but
you'll get an answer okay so that's the
next step so you've got your humble
confession then you've got your
Revelation which is the appearance of a
solution to that now people say when
they describe that that they thought
that up but to me that's an empty
explanatory framework because yeah if
you could think it up why didn't you
know it to begin with and what exactly
did you do to think it up and the answer
is well I asked a question and the
thought arose it's something like that
and you can infer all sorts of
unconscious mechanisms but
phenomenologically the Revelation
appears and it strikes you you know but
that's not enough that's not enough
because you still then have the problem
of potentially delusional or self
deceptive revelation of course but then
there's a there's an
insistance A judeo-christian insistence
in the case that I'm referring to that
you have to test the spirits to see if
they're of God so you have your
confession and your openness to
Revelation you have the receipt of the
Revelation but then the next step is
well you better put that thought to the
test and you know attack it from this
side attack it from this side and test
it out and see if it's got solidity and
weight and to understand its
implications and it's seems to me that
well first of all it seems to me that
that's a variation of the practice of
it's a secularization of the practice of
prayer that's how it looks I mean that
makes sense historically as well but
okay so what do you what do you think
about that well first of all I mean
notice that you were provoked in my
mentioning of insight and the
possibility of systemic Insight yeah
because a deep Revelation would be a
systemic Insight I think so and uh
um yeah there's a lot of work here part
of what I'm doing on sabatical is also
going through all the the most last five
years of the Insight literature try to
keep keep a breast of that um
but
yeah so interesting um both in the
neoplatonic tradition and then Zen
tradition you'll get like I do a
practice every day where I'll say who is
asking the question oh yeah and then
there's a good question yeah and then
who's listening to the
answer whether you're feeling stressed
anxious or simply seeking a moment of
peace and Tranquility the Hallow app has
something for you hallow offers an
incredible range of guided meditations
and prayers that are designed to help
you deepen your spirituality and
strengthen your connection to God with
hallow you can explore different themes
and types of prayer and meditation such
as gratitude forgiveness and centering
prayer you can also choose from
different lengths of meditation to fit
your schedule whether you have a few
minutes or an hour with its userfriendly
interface and hundreds of guided
meditations the Hallow app has quickly
become a go-to resource for people
seeking spiritual growth and healing
download the app for free at hall.com
Jordan you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way hallow
is truly transformative and will help
you connect with your faith on a deeper
level so what are you waiting for
download the Hallow app today at
hall.com Jordan that's hall.com
Jordan hall.com Jordan for an exclusive
3month free trial of all 10,000 plus
prayers and
[Music]
meditations and okay when you get an
answer to that you get a do you get a
vision like are you asking about like a
form of possession so to speak like what
set of motivations are positing this
question and what set of motivations are
offering the answer no see that's that's
the thing I mean I could if I was doing
sort of a phenomenological analysis for
scientific reasons and I do do that but
in this practice what I'm trying to do
is to get at uh aoria to get at
genuinely not knowing what Nicholas ofua
called learned ignorance which is what
Socrates started with he said my wisdom
consists in knowing what I do not know I
call it a an aporetic aperture what
happens is you get a sense of actually I
don't know who's listening what'll
happen is images will come up yeah
that's what I was wondering right and
but then when you go is yes and those
are helpful images but that is I can
just as easily ask what generated the
image yeah and what you get is right you
get you get this falling away and you
get a very profound and frequently
disturbing sense of actually deeply not
knowing but it's not a not knowing um in
the sense that you're you're you're
disconnected from the depths if I can
use that language it's a not knowing
that precisely connects you deeper and
deeper to the depths and then okay so do
you think by doing that that you're are
you attempting to
circumvent what might be regarded as
narrowly self-serving biases in
questioning or answering yes okay and
you're doing that by attempting to
establish a relationship with what's
ineffable at the base instead of
stalling out let's say part way down yes
but but it's nothing I can have it's
only something I can participate in it's
only something I can be I can't have it
right I can't ever it's like James's
distinction between between the eye and
the me which you're familiar with I I I
can never have the eye I can be eye
because I can only be aware of I can
only have the me it's the same kind of
thing there's a no thingness to it but
even saying no thingness sounds like
you're putting a name on an entity what
happens
instead is a falling away of
representational reification of any
attempt to rify things by representing
them and what you get is you
get
in a completely non-inflationary way
because I'm cognizant of who I'm talking
to you get that nothing is excluded but
nothing is enclosed within and without
and there is no within and without you
get to this right now so what's been the
Practical consequences of that practice
for you the Practical consequences of
that is a
abiding
sense that becomes more and more capable
of intervening in my everyday
Consciousness and cognition
of that epistemic and moral at least
that's what I believe is happening what
people are telling me uh humility yeah
well you when I when I saw you today and
started talking to you I thought three
things I thought you look more resigned
you look more hopeful and you look more
humble well thank you yeah yeah well I
don't know what it is exactly well your
expression maybe and your voice tone
like and I mean it's not a dramatic
shift from the last time I saw you but
but it's a shift in the direction that
you just described and the resignation
is interesting cuz I think that's that's
a sign of faith and a sign of humility
you know and it's not people often think
of resignation as pessimistic but it
doesn't like I think of resolution I Ed
to because of the double senses of the
word of coming properly into view like
when you resolve an image but also I am
resolved um um
this I am being called to this
pilgrimage on uh walking the
philosophical Silk Road I this is
my pilgrimage to the god beyond God I am
making myself as available as I possibly
can to that to that and so okay okay so
I mean go ahead well I mean we mentioned
baptism a little earlier and I was
writing about The Descent of the Holy
Ghost in the gospels so that's when
Christ's Ministry starts so it's an
opening of the sory that you described
it's an opening to possession by this
ultimate ineffability and there's a
consequence of that and that's The
Descent of the Holy Spirit and so that
descent we talked earlier about and and
you helped me characterize too in in
different language what that ineffable
Spirit how it might make itself manifest
I talked about the interplay between
conscious and calling and you talked
about you talked about love and you
talked about the axiological
and there was one other dimension sort
of logical transformative the healing
okay so imagine now you open yourself up
to that okay so that's when Christ's
Ministry starts but here's something
very interesting and weird and I'm
interested in your take on
this as soon as the baptism ends Christ
goes into the desert yes okay so now
what that indicates is a radical
transformation of personality so what
was there
before has I wouldn't say it's been
planted but that leaves a a desert
emptiness that's a good way of thinking
about it now so Christ goes out into the
desert it's like the Israelites leaving
theic 40 days tyranny okay so now he's
in the desert and that parallels the is
Israelite desert and then he goes to the
bottom of things so you can imagine this
is a colloquy with conscience that's a
good way of thinking about it so imagine
that you did something wrong and you
decided that you were going to delve
into the depths to understand exactly
why it was that you set yourself up for
that and that you were willing to go
wherever the spirit called you to delve
into the underst structure of that error
so I think that's what happens I think
that's what's being presented in the
sequence of temptations that arises in
the desert so imagine you go into the
landscape of the soul and then you go
down the dependency hierarchy to the
point from which evil emerges that's a
good way of thinking about it it
parallels the notion in Dante's Inferno
yes right cuz Dante's Inferno is a set
of conent Inferno what's that I'm
reading The Inferno oh okay okay so it's
a journey so my sense with The Inferno
is you could take any given proximal and
trivial sin and delve into it and end up
at the bottom and what what Dante
presents is that the meta sin the sin
upon which all others emerges is
something like betrayal right because it
violates trust yeah I
mean for me it's uh it's
betrayal but of the ultimate that is
also idolatry because all of the sins
are are are are versions of idolatry
about loving something in place of
loving God right that's a Tower of Babel
problem too yes yes right and so and
this is TK's notion TK's notion is um
what we're trying to do is uh we're
trying to bring an ultimate concern to
and have it properly conformed to what
is most ultimate um and this is the
Quest for the god beyond the god of
theism but I I see that tunneling down I
mean that I do other practices I do a
spiritual Alchemy practice in which you
um you try to recall moments of profound
hurt and
humiliation uh because those are the
moments where you get the falsification
of the pretentious projections that you
make uh the pretentions to know and to
control both within and with without and
in those moments of hurt and humiliation
you so indicate profound indications of
error and presumption yes yes exactly
exactly so they remove the prese they
they give you now what you try to do is
you try to bring Agape to bear on them
neither Pride nor guilt so that you can
you can you can turn away from the super
salience of the pain and get the
Revelation humiliation right and get the
Revelation though of ab but look there's
an aperture here there's a glimpse of
how things are outside of the pretense
and the presumption and then what you're
trying to do is smelt that and bring see
I think that's the same thing as the
father who's trapped in the belly of the
Beast oh I I think so and this happens
to Jonah you know when Jonah descends
Into the Depths and the consequence of
that is his radical revaluation of his
ethical stance and his reemergence as a
prophet right but he goes all the way
down to the bottom of things he does
that interestingly enough because he
tries to escape both his calling and his
conscience yes right CU god well God
tells him to do something stupidly
impossible and dangerous and he
basically says yeah I don't think so
I've always been fascinated by that
story of course Melville makes a lot of
it in in Moby Dick there's a moment in
that story that I find particularly
compelling and one of the things I like
about the Bible uh is it will have these
little moments of very powerful Humanity
in the mix of wrestling with the
numinous if you remember the story they
come to Jonah the sailors and say what's
going on and he says well you know blah
blah blah blah and God's punishing me
and they don't immediately throw more
they go back and they try to save his
save yeah and I thought yeah what's
what's going on there that's such a
powerful moment and for me right they
only throw them overboard when there's
nothing left to do they try everything
they can they exhaust their human
capacity in the pursuit of this stranger
right and and it's guilty Stranger by
his own admission right and and it would
be so easy to be self-righteous and just
well yeah and throw overboard and
witness the miracle and they put all of
that aside for this and and like and
it's often for me I mean I I I am
often like everyone else I mean
especially coming to the Christmas
season I impressed by the impressive
moments of the the go of the Bible but
but even even that I mean you think
about Elijah right after he has the you
know he defeats the prophets of ball on
Mount Carmel and the fire L fire from
heaven all and then he flees into the
desert and then God you know says come
I'm going to show you something and
there's the big fire and but God's not
in the fire and the big wind and God's
that's the that's conscience there right
the the the still Small Voice Within or
or it sometimes even trans it's also can
be translated as a sheer
silence it's like it can be translated
that way also in the Hebrew and and so
it's it's almost like what we were
talking about before that that I love
this idea of the sence because it's the
ineffable but not as negativity but as
superlative as that which is calling you
because what does he do he he covers his
face in the right he look he beholds
these other do you think there's any
difference between the valid voice of
conscience and the voice of the
ineffable I mean you can if the
ineffable is the foundation and if
conscience is a sign of transgression
against it then those things should be
related well see here's the problem and
this is a this is a problem that goes
back that I have with dayart dayart I
mean and this is a standard
philosophical Trope so I'm not claiming
any originality here uh but daveart
seems to get bunged up on the difference
between a psychological and logical uh
indubitability right uh he gets the
things that he can't doubt and he then
concludes that they're ontologically
certain and of course our inability to
doubt can be driven by many things other
than metaphysical necessity they can be
driven by all kinds of psychologic
issues self-deception issues Demons of
various sorts yeah yes and so and and of
course everybody made continual
philosophical hay out out of that and I
worry also um because this comes up in
Plato Plato's private problem about what
actually turns people towards the good
because of the problem of el sobies um
and I don't trust
any maybe let me try a different word in
I don't idolize any any one of my
faculties I think my conscience can also
be um something that was driven into me
perhaps by aspects of my culture my
parents that's the pathological super
ego problem and I suffer from a sadistic
super ego in a lot of ways and so in in
Pinocchio the puppet has to establish a
relationship with the conscience and it
transforms as well yes right so it's not
an uniring Divine voice from the outset
it's it's something like a generic
approximation that can air and a a
tyrannical great father within would be
an example of that right and I think
part of the socratic project and how
it's unfolded for me often in a
psychologically startling way is to try
and enter into a dialogical relationship
with my conscience with my Consciousness
with my character um and that for me is
one of the great um benefits of the
socratic way of life when they came to
antiy that part testing the spirits I
think so I mean uh so uh Socrates had a
demonium yeah right he had his Divine
sign um and and he said he always
listened to right right he relied on
that in his trial in the apology and
said that that was the thing that made
him different than other men now what's
interesting and many people have said
about this about it um um especially in
what's called Third Way scholarship
platonic scholarship Socrates both
trusts it and always comes up with an
argument around it he never does one or
the other and while we see them as
oppositional he somehow saw them as
deeply dialogical yeah dialogical and
convergent with each other and see when
I was uh uh when I've been in this
journey and I was in the midst of doing
um ifs um I had a very powerful I talk
about this in my after Socrates
experience I had a uh I had
um I I don't know how familiar you are
with ifs internal family systems where
you do Parts work um so what's going on
right now is this huge convergence
within the psychother psychotherapeutic
domain of biological uh models of the
self- diic practices and I was in the
middle of doing Parts work and I was
working with a
part what would that mean practically
what were you doing exactly so what
happens is you what you'll when you
notice that you're sort of possessed by
by something you try and step back your
mother your father an ancestral Spirit
fragment yeah and you try and step back
into
um well Schwarz calls it the uh the the
seed of the self but I don't think
that's quite right but what you try is
you try and step back into that more uh
Sage likee awareness right so you're
going deeper or higher yeah yeah and
then what you do is you try to and you
you don't demonize this part you try and
enter into a dialogue you realize that
it is guarding something this is uh it's
it's it has some adaptive functionality
MH um now this is my take not
necessarily his but I think what what
you do is you bring sort of a a a mirror
of agency or self-reflectiveness to this
part you act like a mindfulness mirror
to it you dialogue and you get it you
get to say well oh well what you try and
get it to explicate its normativity what
how what's actually governing and
guiding it and then you get to and then
you get you call you help it develop
that way yes and you call it and then
you become Socratic with it you call it
to but how much part are you following
the the normativity that you're
enforcing on me yeah and what will
happen frequently is it will relax and
open because it's being listened to it's
being listen to and it's also realized
that there's an opportunity here for for
growth and of course this overlaps with
a lot of so you recommended naming those
things oh you do you name them you name
them but something happened and and and
you'll probably see a very Union thing
in this and like I said this is
difficult for me to talk about but I did
talk about it already public and after
Socrates and I trust hell of a thing for
an introvert to do yes so I was in the
middle of one of these
sessions and an archetypal presence came
in and pushed aside all the parts and
said no you're going to listen to
me
and who are you said I'm
Hermes oh yeah the god of interpretation
the god of meaning making this is you
have little wing slippers on in a little
bit well no he was it was he uh
messenger Wing messenger of the Gods he
yeah he appeared he he very much had
that presence of of like of a psychop PP
um and um and when you mean it when you
say appeared what was the phenomenology
what was happen the phenomenology is
like the phenomenology of the presence
of a mind like I have a sense of I have
a mindsight into your um awareness now
what's interesting about these things
and this is again my take not um the ifs
people although I've talked to Mark
Lewis at length about this and uh he
thinks it's a good take
um I think of these entities as neither
subjective nor objective I think of them
transc and I think is in the domain of
relevance and relevance is neither
objective nor subjective but what binds
them together right he's binding the
inner and the outer the upper and the
lower and all of that together and and
so it's the sense of a presence but it's
it's like what Charles Stang talks about
the Divine double it's both you and not
you kind of like the way conscience is
but it has a it h it right I mean and so
I have an ongoing dialogue with Hermes
it's very much um is this some is this a
presence that you visualized how how do
you know of its appearance I've had only
one sort of vision of what was the
vision like uh the vision was very M
well I've had uh the vision was very
much uh what I later very much like sort
of Micah L the Archangel uh which is
very interesting um and then I've had
one of sort of tho from Egypt and
Hanuman from the viic tradition as well
as Hermes the from the Greek tradition
um and they they've they in the ancient
literature they're often seen as
corresponding to each other in some
fashion um you understand I'm chatting
on this very okay so what was the
consequence of the appearance of this
superordinate Spirit arguably
superordinate spirit in the presence of
this domain of chaos well one I mean it
it made it very clear to me that it uh I
don't want to say it anymore he wanted
to make it very clear that um um there
was a dialogical relationship that
needed to be developed and cultivated um
and it would be a
relationship uh by which I would
cultivate something analogous to
Socrates demonium that was the promise
that was given oh oh that's a good deal
I think so um well it's dangerous but so
is everything
else yeah excellent things are rare or
we wouldn't pursue them as Spinosa said
uh or we would all pursue them as
Spinosa said um so I found raph's work
on Ally work um and I've talked to a
bunch of people that have uh you know
the kind of practices you can do uh to
enter into this Anderson taught a friend
of mine very helpful around this um and
so what became very apparent was that um
uh that
this demonium and the way of I I've
internalized Socrates as a sage were
very Allied to each other because
Socrates also portrayed himself as being
maxu being between uh the human and the
Divine and then to to get to the Deep
answer to this this all started to
Psycho dynamically integrate with the
intellectual philos opical realization
of the platonic proposal that human
beings are supposed to always hold in
tonos Creative tension Nicholas of kuza
heraclitus our finitude and our
Transcendence if we only hold on to our
finitude we fall prey to servitude and
despair if we only hold on to our
Transcendence we fall prey to hubris and
inflation but if we can hold the two
together if we are the maxu between the
Beast and the God right uh we can
properly realize our humanity and this
is what Socrates sees himself this is
how he portrays AOS this is how he
portrays the task of philosophia and so
for me that Socratic spirit and Hermes
as a psychological biological presence
have become integrated uh together um so
that's that's that's quite a
trip well I
mean
that's very much like it's very much the
conscious equivalent of a Dream It's
like a dream yeah but what's intriguing
is the platonic Socratic possibility of
it being filled as much with logos as it
is with Mythos uh that there is also as
much because when I when I dialogue I
write out dialogues with Hermes yeah
it's very much at at times it's very
much like encountering an archetypal
figure there's all this have you read
the red book I've read parts of it
because it's what you're talking about
is quite reminiscent of what of the
sorts of exercises that Yung over
undertook well what what you find out is
this is also deeply reminiscent of a lot
of theurgic practices that were going on
in the neoplatonic tradition as I've
come to discuss um and then get taken up
into Eastern Orthodox Christianity by
dionis and Gregory Shaw has done some
excellent scholarship showing that um so
let let okay let me but I just want to
make clear that there is a lot of
rationality in this discourse where I
don't mean sort of cartisian logicality
I mean the calling to the full person
recognition and responsibility towards
the ongoing proclivity to self-deception
and trying to comprehensively address it
uh and seek
systematic it's a deole and and and to
and it's not there's something
mysterious about it in Marcel's sense if
you ever think you've got a full
phenomenological grasp on the engine of
self-deception within you you of course
have fallen prey to one of the deepest
forms of self-deception so whenever you
think you frame it you have to not
idolize this is tiic again you have to
not idolize that framing you have to
constantly it has to be constantly open
to
self-correction yeah well the opposite
of self-deception is probably something
like the constant openness to
self-correction rather than a stance per
se I was de now I have the truth it's
like no there's a process by which you
continually discover the truth and
allegiance to that is the opposite of
self so that's what my I would call my
faith my faith is a faithfulness to a
process of self-correction not to any
one faculty as the voice of the Divine I
think the capacity for um the self
correction to take on a life of its own
and a life on its own that plugs into uh
transpersonal and transc of aspects of
my being
for me that is better I'm very impressed
that you managed to bring all of that
back to the point where it started by
the way so I would say in relationship
to that that first of all that I agree
that that in fact the eye that's at the
top of the pyramid let's say the Eye of
Horus that's at the Pinnacle of the
pyramid is a representation as far as
I'm concerned of the aware attention
that allows for continual
self-correction and part of the
implication of the ancient Egyptian
theology is that nothing should be put
higher on the higher up in the Pyramid
of value than the thing that's gold at
the top that's associated with the open
eye that's right watch and attend and
and in that Spirit of you said guilt
free there was two criteria you had free
of guilt and free of pride pride yes
just apprehension of what's there in
front of your this is Christ says
something like this too this is in the
Gospel of Thomas though he says the
kingdom of God is spread upon the Earth
but men either do not or will not see it
the will not being the more interesting
one as far as I'm concerned and part of
that organization of the psychological
hierarchy to put the the ey not the
letter I but the ey on top is to
prioritize that NE neutral isn't exactly
right it's an attention that's oriented
towards the highest ineffable good to
put that above everything else now I
would say that I wasn't trying to reduce
that to conscience and calling I didn't
think you were okay okay I I was
thinking about those as what would you
call they're part of the dynamic process
of attention that allows the attention
per se to rise to the top so because I
could pay attention careful attention to
how it is that I'm calling myself out
let's say in a Socratic manner because
you also are granted the right to the
presumption of innocence right so even
if you're accused yourself it's
perfectly reasonable to set up a defense
but there's a starting point with the
prodding of conscience if conscience
prods you two questions come up one is
I'm falling prey to an internal tyranny
the other is I'm wrong well you need to
figure out which of those two is right
you can do that dialogically you can do
that in conversation with someone as
well and calling is the same thing I
would say is that a calling can emerge
as a consequence of your possession by a
particular ideological Spirit or it can
be a manifestation of the real thing and
like it's up to you to tread very
carefully to make sure you get those
right and then the dynamic interplay of
those two things is even more reliable
probably especially if you share it with
other people there's a I've been
thinking about the Exodus story of the
burning bush in terms of calling and I
think it Maps very nicely onto our
discussion of depth because and you tell
me what you think about this so when
Moses encounters the burning bush things
are actually not going so bad for him
now he's escaped from Egypt so he's
freed himself from tyranny and now he's
got himself two young wives and he's
doing pretty well with his father-in-law
who he gets along with and he's a
shepherd and so it's not like he's no
longer an Egyptian Aristocrat but you
know all things considered he has a
perfectly stable and productive ordinary
life now he's wandering around and it's
near Mount Si by the way which is the
place where the Divine and the proximal
meat and this thing glimmers and catches
his attention it's like a manifestation
of Hermes yes and so he decides to step
off the Beaten Track as a consequence of
this calling and invitation and he moves
closer and closer to this manifestation
of the sublime and as he moves closer he
starts to understand that he's on sacred
ground and I don't think there's
anything different than that than than
noting what it is that calls to you and
then pursuing it and going down into the
depths as a consequence and eventually
what happens to Moses because he
continues his Pursuit is that the voice
of being itself speaks to him and that's
when he's also transformed into the kind
of leader who can fight tyranny and
slavery so that's excellent um that's
why it's Moses and Elijah by the way I
think that end up at the Transfiguration
because you have Elijah as the well they
also both the they both encounter the
fire of God they they're both they both
but but they're interesting parallels
because it's Elijah who's the first
proponent of the notion that God is not
an external phenomenon associated with
the natural world associated with B but
this internal voice and its conscience
for Elijah and then for Moses the God
that he encounters seems to be the god
of calling and so and they they're like
on what would you say one on each side
of Christ which is you know mindboggling
narrative
representation there's a lot I want to
talk to you but let me try one thing
because it there there's a there's I
want to Circle back to the question of
sacred and and God and the god beyond
God um so so one of the things that I
find interesting in the fire of course
is the it it it burns but it does not
burn up right um and so um this goes
towards a neoplatonic model too and of
course Plato is it's the Sun the image
of the Sun but it's the same thing the
fire that burns and is not burnt up at
least in Greek mythology um and
heraclitus said that the cosmos was that
too um what am I getting at I'm getting
at this notion all those associations CU
I'm associating The long-standing
Association of Fire and logos by the way
they're Associated
together so the sacred also seems we've
been talking a lot about the serological
and the axiological and the ultimate but
I want to return to something that I
think binds them together which
is the the neoplatonic notion of the
sacred as uh inexhaustible Fountain of
intelligibility so the that never runs
dry the tow right yes the da right
absolutely and and let me give you a
concrete experience of that I I I I I'm
going to assume given what you've said
that this is the case for you in the
gospels um I have a different
relationship with the Bible we can
perhaps talk about that but for me the
Republic does this for me Plato's
Republic I will read the Republic and
it's inevitably transformative there's a
reciprocal opening I see something in
the text I haven't seen it opens me up I
go into to my life my lo my life opens
up I'm transformed I come back after a
bit and I read the text and it opens
itself up again to me and I and it's
inexhaustible there's this inexhaustible
Fountain uh and so there's some
sacredness in there I think this is um
uh you know this is the present the the
the opportunity to enter into a
Conformity with the good with the one
right and so I for me there's a positive
in this u in the experience of the
sacred and the reason I want to do that
is I want to complement and I use that
word exactly complement you know the
call and the conscience with also this
notion of of being fed of being
nourished um I'm doing I'm reading a
book on lexio deina by uh what's his
name the latter of the monks and he he
talks about when you're reading the text
and you're you're actually being
nourished by it and of course there's
the Mana from Heaven all that stuff and
and of course you can't grasp it because
if you try and grasp it and store it
you'll lose it and all that sort of
blakean stuff that's there and so I want
to this this idea also of a fountain an
inexhaustible Fountain of
intelligibility
and if neoplatonism is right and I think
philosophy at least some philosophy and
a lot of philosophy of physics and of
biology is pointing towards to which is
that there is a non-logical Oneness
between intelligibility and being the
way we get at what most real is we we we
Trace out the asymmetric dependence
relationships of intelligibility that's
based on a faith in parmen proposal that
somehow thinking and being are one
they're not identical but they're one in
some because if they're if they're
fundamentally not conformable we are
bound into skep something Richard
Dawkins said an adapted organism is by
necessity a microcosm of its environment
yes and friston has said this we don't
have models we are models and I
I've made similar arguments based on the
stunning work of Katherine pix and
others uh for extended naturalism but we
can perhaps come back to that in a sec
so let me let
me because I've been thinking about this
and and there's a concern for idolatry
here and I think you're in many ways
maybe the perfect person to talk to
about this um so I'm going to say
something and then give me a moment
around it
y i find Plato's
Republic and I find
let's say my relationship to my beloved
partner we made a lifetime commitment to
each other right um there's something
sacred there in
that I continue I I've come to realize I
will never sound her depths completely
and right and there's a way in which
that's a good deal yeah it is a good
deal and I have I've made a lot of
horrible mistakes to get there um and
appreciative for those errors um and for
the people that actually hurt me in some
ways
uh because they that hurting was a
sensitivity that allowed me to see her
first person I fell in love with their
soul before I fell in love with their
physical
Beauty that's a good
order I'm not responsible for it I just
happen but you can be responsible for
being grateful for it I am I am
continually grateful yeah well that's a
good deal too so um now why am I
bringing this up I think these things
are properly
sacred but I don't think while while
they are symbols in the yian toian sense
they are not themselves the one they are
not the
ultimate um and
so I am I'm just I'm going to talk about
a practice I've adopted so I'm not
advocating for this as a metaphysical
proposal but I've been using the term
the one or God for when we experience
ultimacy as sacred not just something
pointing to the
but ultimacy itself and and that we so
so that's a very restricted usage and
careful it is it's careful because you
again the concern is the concern defense
against idolatry too idolatry yes that's
the concern is the concern for idolatry
and the and but there also the Zen
concern of ultimately not being bound to
your representations But realize they
have an ongoing as a like asymmetric
toting towards
reality right and that you so like this
the Cohen is right is the commitment to
no matter what I'll do my thought will
have representation but I'm always
trying to push towards that which low is
below rep representation all my work on
relevance realization helps me because
that's much lower than the level of
representation much more Prim right
right so I wanted to I wanted to put
those two things together in a that's
meaning as the ultimate instinct yeah
whereas what if what we mean by meaning
is religio if we mean to be connected to
something that has a reality and a value
beyond my existence that's that
nourishing aspect that's the nourishing
aspect but it's it's interesting because
what happens is once we are well at
least what seems to be happening for me
and what I read in in the texts I'm
reading is once we get a certain degree
of nourishment we are more and more
capable of because we're primate mammals
of turning the arrow of relevance
outward agapic right not how are things
relevant to me but ultimately how I can
be relevant to them the meaning in life
literature this is how you find out if
people have meaning in life what do you
want to exist even if you don't and how
much of a difference do you make to it
now you have a good answer to both of
those you've got say them again what do
you want to exist even if you
don't yeah and how much of a difference
do you make to it now yeah and that's
that's not brought those down yeah so I
think the only do you have an answer to
those yes would you share
them so for
me my
religio
to the sacred realization of
ultimacy is that that gives me those the
answers and so all of the projects that
I'm engaged in that that help people for
themselves not for me but for themselves
either individually and collectively
realize that that gives me a sense of
meaning in life and what are you doing
about that would you
say those are the proximal actions that
are imbued with meaning by that
Transcendent goal yes so I mean a big
part of it is all the work I'm doing
with and for the verveacu foundation new
series but also the academic work I'm
doing all of my academic scientific work
about intell and rationality I've just
recently been integrated the relevance
realization and the predictive
processing framework in a lot in a way
that a lot of people are finding very
valuable all of that has I I think I
think it's fair to say because other
people are saying it to me it has
scientific Merit I'm happy about that
but it's all oriented towards uh this uh
what I've I've pointed because for me
it's not just the call away from
self-deception the call of conscience
it's it's the call it's the calling to a
fullness which isn't a completion it's
it's that it's that sense of religio
that meaning in life that so that I'm
and I feel that I have experiences of
what is Ultimate
as um as sacredness experiences
experiences of Sac things that are
calling the whole of me to a commitment
right and that's the genuine answer to
the problem of relevance realization and
the meaning crisis to find out what's
actually meaningful so let let me offer
you something in relation okay so I
talked to Sam Harris recently again and
one of the places that Sam and I find
firm Mutual ground is in a concern
metaphysical concern with evil so Sam
was really struck to the soul I would
say by the reality of evil associated in
his case particularly with what happened
in owitz and places like that so Sam is
metaphysically convinced of the
existence of evil and that's been an
orienting point for him and part of the
reason that he wanted to ground his
ethical metaphysics in objective science
was because he didn't feel that there
was a better way of demonstrating the
reality of good in relationship to evil
unless that grounding was possible now
I've been thinking about that as I've
been writing what I'm writing but I took
a different tack I would say to some
degree than Sam even though maybe the
net end goal is the same as it was by
the way for PJ because that was his
project right right from the beginning
so because PJ wanted to reconcile
materialism with metaphysics and so in
any
case I've been thinking a fair bit
about what's real in terms of meaning
and
one of
the people have very little doubt that
pain is real they certainly act as if
it's real you can't it's very difficult
not to act as if pain is real and one of
the consequences of that realization is
that you can therefore very rapidly
claim that whatever rectifies pain most
effectively is even more real and then
you might ask what rectifies pain most
effectively and so here's a couple of
here's something not to do think about
your a lot your your proximal immediate
demands and needs so you know that
relationship between narrow
self-consciousness and suffering is so
high that they load on the same factor
in fact Factor analytic studies of
negative emotion so if you're
self-conscious that narrow self you are
miserable this is what I meant just one
small intervention that I'll let you go
this is what I meant about this is
Plato's pivot problem how do you involve
all of the psyche without becoming self-
involved in that narrow that n narrow
pain you know self-inflicting suffering
loss of agency on this is Plato's thing
about how do because we need to involve
all of you this is till too that's his
definition of spirit that which involves
the whole of the psyche but how do you
get all of that involved with while
resisting the magnetism maybe it's also
partly by realizing that it's not only
all of the psyche it's all of the psyche
embedded in the whole structure of being
simultaneously right this is part of the
reason that our current
conceptualizations of Mental Health
suffer from such a posi of content of of
conceptualization because we view mental
health as something like Harmony in the
subjective world but that's like you're
talking about the mysteries of your
relationship I mean it's obvious from
talking to you that part of the reason
that you're as sane as you are and as
happy as you are is not because
immediately because you're well
constituted as a subjective creature but
because you've established a Harmony of
existence in relationship at least to
one other person you want that more
broadly and that means that you have to
be called to service for something
that's certainly not localized to the
like narrowness of you now yes be okay
because your phenomenological markers
subjective well-being don't track
meaning in life they come apart they can
move uh they can move opposite to each
other this is what happens when you have
what happens to job well but it's also
what happens when if you have a child
and you and you enter into committed all
of your measures of subjective
well-being collapse and if you ask
people why they do it and they're giving
you a healthy answer not they fell into
it or they IR responsible but they've
chosen Parenthood yeah and and and and
and they're going through what La Paul
calls a transformative experience
something you can't understand until you
go through it so very much right this
this act of faithfulness right what
happens is why they do it is because
they say it makes their life more
meaningful because they're connected to
something that has a reality Beyond
there beyond the immediate yes and
Beyond subjective self-report right and
they and and it's an entity they want to
exist even if they don't in fact they're
willing to sacrifice their life for it
right and right they feel that they make
a difference to it this is the agapic
concern their love is person not morally
person I mean cognitive person it's
creative of I mean when you bring a
child home they're obviously a moral
person I'm not talking moral but they're
not a cognitive person and this we we
get to partake in this miracle like we
we we shine Agape on them which isn't
AOS which isn't FIA all right that's not
your friend it's not something you want
to be one with in fact the project is
the opposite you're trying to make it
autonomous from you right right a major
sacrifice yes it's agape and and and and
it's just an astonishing thing it's like
it's like magic so one of the things I
figured out by going through the Book of
Job is allied with what you just
described so there's a moral proposition
in Job that has to do with the
segregation between immediate subjective
well-being let's say and long-term
meaning so job's proposition is so he's
Things Fall Apart very badly for job
right yes and we know he's a good man
because that's stated right at the
beginning right that's axiomatic okay
but his friends attribute blame to him
and he basically says well yeah
I'm sinful but no better than the no
worse than the typical good man and so
you can't just dump all this at my feet
I'm not going to take myself apart in
the face of my misery and decimate my
soul in addition to my suffering and
then his wife says well shake your fist
at God and die and job says well I have
some reason to do that given the
tragedies that have befallen me but at
minimum I'm going to suspend judgment
and better than that I'm going to retain
my faith in the essential goodness of
existence regardless of the proximal
evidence and then there's a deeper
consideration in job which is you're
called upon to do that no matter what
and that is definitely a place where
measures of say subjective well-being
and ultimate meaning are going to
separate because the moral impetus in
the Book of Job is that you're called to
maintain your Allegiance with what is
highest no matter what proximal price
you currently might be paying and then
you can even think about that
practically which I think is a useful
thing to do it's like if you're stricken
with a terminal and painful disease
let's say and maybe coincidentally a
series of financial catastrophes just to
make it a little bit worse and maybe
your family's also dumping heaps of coal
on your head
um you have every reason to descend into
a kind of nihilistic bitterness but then
you might say well to what end now you
have your illness you have your
financial catastrophe you have your
moral culpability and you have your
bitter nihilism to contend with the one
thing you do have if you're fortunate
and I would say also God willing that it
is in the face of multiple dimensions of
simultaneous catastrophy the refusal to
take the path of nihilistic bitterness
and to shake your fist at the world and
that's not nothing you know maybe that
wouldn't be enough to rescue you from
the dire states that you're in but it
might be enough to stop you from sending
to the ultimate possible
hell I really love talking with you I I
I want to respond because um um I I want
to talk about my take on
job um and how when I finally got job
was I was actually watching a Tom Hanks
movie called joob Versus the Volcano
which is a very silly movie it's a farce
but it's a guy who discovers he's only
got a year to live and he goes on the
proverbial last great journey and of
course it becomes a quest and he doesn't
realize it there's a scene where he he's
Shipwrecked and he's on a raft made of
luggage and there's a girl that he's
taking care of and she's unconscious and
he's giving her the last remaining water
so he's starting to suffer from
exposure and so he's uh by all measures
of to dtive well-being he's at the worst
he's literally lost he's a drift he's
Cast Away he's suffering physically the
one person he's with is unconscious and
he's caring for them and they're not
they're not capable of reciprocating at
all it's very powerful image I don't
know how this scene got in this movie I
think the staff writers went on lunch
break and G they gave the intern a
moment to to write a thing and then what
happens is and it's astonishing well
done there's a moonrise and it's the
Moon Illusion and the music swells and
he o calm ocean and he struggles and he
rises to his feet and he opens his arms
and he says oh God whose name I do not
know
thank you for my life I had forgotten
how and he struggles and it's not the
right word but he just spits it out how
big thank you for my life none of his
problems have been
solved and what I what what I took from
that is what happens at the end of job
when God Appears and starts showing job
all these astonishing things and he's
saying and God and God is don't forget
about the wonder of the world well and
also the numinous the numinous
oh that's interesting right and the and
the numinous and what the numinous says
even in even in its monstrous forms yes
even in the they speak of transcendence
and God is saying I am that presence
that goes to the very depth of the
numinous both the happy forms and the
and and this is supposed to be the thing
that is the answer right right and go
job does reattain his fortune in the
aftermath of that encounter and and what
happens with Joe is he he he gets
gratitude for his life I may steal that
put it in my book well and I'll tribute
you well thank you now what what that
speaks to me is that there are these
three things and this I think has to do
with the transcendentals the true and
the good and beautiful they're all
convertible but they're also not um
reducible they're not logically
identical to each other and I think one
and these three Leo and I talked about
this in the the article we wrote on
wisdom one is kind of sensory motor
Mastery if you don't have sort of
sensory motor Mastery over your
environment if you're not be if you're
not solving the Frisian problems of
relevance realization and anticipation
you're you're just B with anxiety your
life's going okay so there's that but
then there's the excellent work uh by
Susan Wolf and others and this really is
something that our society is not well
set up to reflect upon right now is that
meaning in life and morality you can't
reduce one to the
other okay okay so she gives the she
gives many examples of well you know
double dissociation means you can't make
an identity claim right um is it
possible for somebody to leave a very
highly moral existence and yet have a
life that it's not going to be
absolutely lacking in meaning because
that's impossible for human existence
but it's very a life that's not very
meaningful by many measures and she says
yes consider the very real possibility
of somebody who is leading a very moral
life but is very
lonely
their lives there's nothing that they're
doing that's especially imoral maybe
they're very honest maybe could happen
to a good person in a totalitarian state
many things yes and their lives could be
very bere right so there can be a
dissociation and you can think of the
other can we think of people who maybe
had very powerful meaning in life and
yet were leading highly immoral
existences of course we can I mean uh
they're thoroughly possessed those
people yes so what you can see is just
like subjective well-being and meaning
and life come apart morality and meaning
and what that does well it shows you at
least to some degree that morality isn't
reducible to emotional state well it
also shows that meaning in life can't be
satisfied also just by being a highly
moral person you so that connectedness
that we need it has sort of three
dimensions to it one is the dimension of
sensory motor Mastery one is the
production promotion protection of
personhood that's what I take morality
to be
and the other is a connection what what
do you mean I'm I'm confused a bit about
that there's part of me that's objecting
in the background here let's slow down
and let's listen Okay well just it's
just that I'm not sure exactly what you
mean by moral you know let let me give
you an example something that came to
mind so solit and talks in in the gag
archipelago and I have to bring that up
one once per podcast by necessity know
um about these intellectuals who are in
a a camp being worked to death and they
had a seminar that they would conduct
once a week and they would all meet and
they would talk about their specialty
and they were com men committed to their
scientific Endeavor who had been
imprisoned because of for ideological
reasons and uh they took the opportunity
to share what they loved and every week
one or more of them would disappear
right because they were dying
now what they were engaged in was a
moral endeavor you could say that the LI
the meaning of their life was pretty
bitter at that point they were all
starving to death or freezing to death
or both being beaten at the low end of
the totem pole in the gag hierarchy um
watching the people around them
die but they were doing something
profoundly ethical adhering to something
they saw as a positive good acting
morally and there would be a meaning in
that like the the surround is pretty
damn dismal but but they're getting
together and do the Seminars the
seminars aren't a moral Endeavor the
seminars are a meaning Endeavor what do
you love what are you connected to what
do you want what what do you want to
exist even if you
don't I don't know how to separate them
the the fact of the action oriented
towards that good and morality per se I
I get your argument look I can certainly
see the utility in dissociating
emotional state especially proximal
emotional state from me as such or
purpose I mean delay of gratification is
that fundamentally but but I'm I'm I'm
still struggling with no but perhaps let
me suggest something back so I'm using
morality the way um I think wolf is
using it the way that it's you been used
sort of post Enlightenment postc which
is your commitment to a sense of Duty
born from something like the categorical
imperative okay okay I see you're
talking
I think a platonic notion ofs right
right where we talking about human
flourishing now interestingly enough
Kant goes on to argue that if you do
something out of love then it is
expressly not a moral act because if
you're doing it for anything other than
the sense of Duty right well he's hyper
conscientious well so do you think that
that's the morality that Christ is
pointing to in the gospels where he
states that unless your ethical striving
exceed needs that characterizing the
Pharisees the Hypocrites the scribes the
academics the lawyers the legalistic
types that it's not a true ethic at all
and that the morality that you're
describing that would be dissociable
from meaning is more the hypocritical or
or academic or legalistic type I I think
totally I think okay that resolves the
problem that that I was having I and I
think Paul wrestles with this and I
think there's ways I'm critical of it
when he's talking about law and love
the two different things and so what I
think happens in job and what I think
happens in Jo versus a volcano is job uh
or Joe uh perhaps job to Joe recovers a
gratitude for his life not because any
of his moral in that in this other
sense there is no proof that the world
is just right all that's been happened
is he has been opened to a connection a
contact
with what's numinous and that is
sufficient I think that's what's also
happening at the end so the reason why I
bring this up is because my lab we're
doing a lot of work on um uh
post-traumatic stress disorder and how
it looks like a violation of the hyper
prior of ajust world hypothesis right
right and and what we're pursuing one of
the things we're doing is we're seeing
of meaning generating meaning in life
generating not semantic meaning like the
dialectic into Theos practices that I
right if they can restore people's sense
of religio connectedness meaning in life
yeah that helps heal them from the
trauma without trying to argue them into
that this is ultimately a just world see
that's this is this is what I'm this is
what I'm hoping for I'm hoping that
these that's an experiential replacement
for a logical argument in some ways and
I and I think more it's more real than
well one of the things that I always did
with my clients in in therapy sometimes
for post-traumatic stress reasons was
this is where it's not cognitive it's
like the first thing I would do often
was a differential diagnosis let's say
for people who are depressed okay so
there's two part there's more than two
but there's two possibilities okay one
is that you're depressed the other is
that you have a terrible life okay so
let's take those apart do you have a
partner do you have friends do you have
family do you have a job do you have Ed
educational resources at hand you know
are you embedded in a structure of
meaning a multi-dimensional structure of
meaning where you find purchase and if
the answer to all those questions is no
and sometimes that is the answer then
you're not depressed yeah like you might
be sad and guilt-stricken and lonely and
anxious and show all the symptoms of
depression but your fundamental problem
is that well you have nothing now you
can take someone who's completely
different in that you can and you find
people like this they're doing fine in
all those evaluations dimensions of
evaluation and they're depressed I found
by the way that those were often people
who responded well to an
anti-depressant right because their
depression wasn't a consequence of the
failure of these embedded structures
that you described now if you're dealing
with someone who who has a terrible life
that's when you
do that's when you revert to the level
of behavior it's like okay well why
don't we see if we can make you a friend
and then we can evaluate the
consequences of that we got 50 things
here to work on we can work on one of
them and see if that produces a concrete
difference has very little to do with
cognitive restructuring except in so far
as the person might have to restructure
their cognitions terrible cliche written
phrase to allow themselves to risk
attempting to make a friend of course
right but but it I I see the the same
thing working quite well in the
treatment of something like
post-traumatic stress disorder it's like
well you don't want to retool your
explicit representation of the world
necessarily but you want to you might
want to see if you can expand the
discovery of true intrinsic meaning
within your life the other thing that
that's often recommended by behavioral
therapists is
that say if you're having someone track
their moods if they're depressed across
a
week they do that every 2 hours and then
you see variability even though they may
say they're depressed all the time
there's usually variability well one of
the things you find out is okay what
were you doing when you were worse and
what were you doing when you were better
and could we have you do a little less
of what you were doing when you were
worse and a little more of what you were
doing that's an empirical collaborative
empiricism essentially is how is how
that's described that's very powerful I
found those behavioral techniques
generally much more powerful than any
mere cognitive real evaluation not
always but but often well I yeah I I
mean I uh I would say that that's
because ultimately for e cogi is Right
cognitions embodied embedded enacted and
extended and the propositional knowing
is sitting on top of the procedural the
perspectival and the participatory and
you have to bring oh you know that's
actually one of the primary things I
wanted to talk to you about today maybe
we'll do that on the daily wire side
because we have another half an hour
okay let's do that so for those of you
who are watching and listening um you
can join us on the daily wire side we're
going to continue this conversation but
in a pretty targeted Direction I want to
talk to John about the embedding of
explicit knowledge the kind of knowledge
you can communicate verbally let's say
in other systems of representation and
memory because it sounds like we're
dovetailing with regards to the way
we're theorizing about this so if you
want to join us I also want to talk to
John about uh the academic reception of
his work and his sense of his impact in
the broader public sphere so we'll do
that on the daily wire plus side I think
we came to a good ending point otherwise
for this discussion even though I just
soon keep talking to you like for the
next week but we'll do it again in the
not too distant future like that so yeah
yeah and so for everybody watching and
listening thank you very much for your
time and attention and to the Daily wire
people for making this possible that's
much appreciated the film crew here and
John thank you Happy New Year to you
Happy New Year to youo really good to
see you man yeah good to see so join us
on the dailywire plus side if you're
[Music]
inclined